On this day in history, we witnessed a
moment so packed with courage and fury
that even the most over-the-top
Hollywood battle scenes struggled to
match it. Christian knights led by none
other than Richard the Lionheart
launched an audacious attack and routed
a massive Muslim army just days after
those same forces had been torturing and
slaughtering helpless Christians. Let's
rewind.
The date is July 27th, 1192. Saladin,
the Islamic Sultan celebrated in both
Muslim and Western lore, has laid siege
to the Christian held town of Jaffa.
Contemporary sources describe his force
as vast, up to 20,000 men, harrowing the
land like a quote swarm of locusts. It's
a full-blown crisis. Urgent messengers
are sent racing to King Richard I, who's
in a preparing to head back to England.
But before the full message even reaches
him, Richard doesn't hesitate. With God
as my guide, I will do what I can, he
declares, and immediately sets sail with
a force just slightly over 2,000 men.
Meanwhile, inside Jaffa, the situation
is desperate. The defenders are barely
holding out. Saladin's own chronicler,
Baha Alin, who witnessed the siege
firsthand, described how Muslim forces
breached the walls and poured into the
city. Fear spread fast, but the
Christians fought harder. As Beah Alin
admits, quote, "There was not an enemy
heart that did not tremble and shake."
But the Christians were more fierce and
determined in the fight and more eager
for and devoted to death. Just before
the Muslims could overwhelm the main
gate, and as the walls began to
collapse, something incredible happened.
A cloud of dust and smoke rose, blocking
the sky. And when it cleared, Muslim
attackers found the wall had been
replaced not with stone, but with a wall
of crusaders, spears, and lances. Their
message was clear. You'll only get
through us when we're dead. But even the
most determined defense has limits. As
Muslim numbers surged, the remaining
Christian fighters fell back into the
citadel. That's when the real horror
began. Muslim troops turned to the
unarmed and the sick. Chronicles from
the time record brutal, inhuman
tortures, slaughter not just of
soldiers, but of the defenseless,
including women and children. Now, back
to Richard. His fleet reaches the coast
on the evening of July 31st. But what he
sees isn't encouraging. Muslim banners
fly all across the city. Cries of there
is no god but Allah and Allah Akbar echo
across the sea. It looks like Jaffa has
already been taken. To make matters
worse, the Muslims on shore begin
bombarding the fleet with spears,
javelins, and arrows, trying to prevent
any landing. There is nowhere to set
foot. The shore is packed with enemy
troops. But then, just before dawn on
August 1st, a Christian priest trapped
inside the citadel jumps 70 ft into the
sea. He swims against all odds out to
the fleet. His message, the city is
mostly lost. The castle is overrun. But
some defenders are still holding out.
Richard doesn't flinch. If it be God's
will, says he, we will die here with our
brothers. The lion heart doesn't even
bother with his full armor. He throws on
chain mail, slings his shield around his
neck, grabs a Danish ax, and carries a
crossbow in one hand, shouting, "Death
only to those who do not advance." He
jumps into the water and charges ashore
under fire. He's shooting bolts,
blocking arrows with his axe, fighting
his way through surf, sand, and steel.
And that changes everything. The
crusaders, seeing their king's mad
courage, follow. They plunge into the
water after him and launch a full-on
assault. Here's an actual drawing of
this surreal event from the 19th century
artist Gustav Dor. And now it's the
Muslim forces who panic. They remember
who this is. They fought him before and
they don't want a second round. They
begin to fall back. Richard chases them
sword in hand. He cuts down the fleeing
enemy, striking them down as they run.
One chronicle recounts, quote, "The king
fell on them with unshathed sword,
pursued them, beheaded, and slew them
all. They fled before him, falling back
in dense crowds. The slaughter is total.
Then Richard goes even further. Drenched
in blood, the Lionhe Heart pushes
forward directly towards the mighty
Sultan's own camp. Muslim arrows rain
down on him. But he doesn't stop. His
goal is clear. Face Saladin himself. And
what does the great Sultan do? He runs.
According to the sources, quote, he puts
spur to horse and fled before King
Richard, not wishing to be seen by him.
A full retreat, humiliating, disorderly.
The worst defeat Salin would suffer
before his death just months later.
Richard and his knights pursued them for
over two miles, cutting down fleeing
soldiers, unhorsing others, and utterly
shattering the Muslim army. Richard had
proven his own words true. Victory goes
to the brave, and God will not forsake
his servants. And that's why even today,
Richard the Lionheart remains a feared
and hated figure all throughout the
Middle East and in parts of the Islamic
world in general. He's the crusader
boogeyman. The man who humiliated
Saladin, the Christian king who stood
alone on a beach and broke an entire
army. In fact, his name still carries so
much weight that even in modern times,
it can provoke trouble. Indeed, let me
share something personal. Both of my
parents have names that start with an R.
As such, they wanted to give me a name
starting with R. And their first choice
was Richard. But in the end, they
decided against it, afraid that if we
ever return to Egypt, a name like
Richard might draw hostility and worse
from those still bitter over the
Crusades. So instead, they chose Raymond
without realizing it's another crusader
name. In other words, 900 years later,
it's only the name of Richard that is
still remembered that still offends
Muslim sensibilities. And maybe, just
maybe, that's a legacy worth keeping.
Thanks for watching. If you think
stories like this deserve to be
remembered, especially the ones they'd
rather you forget, don't forget to like,
comment, and subscribe. Incidentally,
this video was entirely based on the
chapter dedicated to Richard the Lionhe
Heart in my book, Defenders of the West:
The Christian Heroes Who Stood Against
Islam, which is packed with many such
tales.